[Music]
[Music]
this week guys we have a couple of
strangers actually returning guest
members to the podcast Chris and Shan
welcome to the podcast thank you very
much all right so what do you guys have
for us yeah upstairs are they Raptor oh
not yet no well a good gift that you
don't even need a rapid Squarespace
because it is a great website hosting
service and right now if you're looking
to build a website do it with
Squarespace okay they have plenty of
templates they have 24/7 customer
support and right now you can get 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain when you go to squarespace.com
slash Jenna and Julian check it out
think it dream it make it with
Squarespace okay so well Squarespace so
my fellow Parks and Recreation fans out
there are gonna really appreciate
today's podcast but everyone else is
gonna also appreciate it because it's
fun regardless but we're gonna play a
version of the newlywed game but it's
called know you boo
and we found a jeopardy version online
so we have this this kind of board looks
like a Jeopardy board with five
different categories and we are gonna
see how well we all know our boo so it's
gonna mean me and Jenna versus Chris and
Shan huh are you gonna keep score yeah
so we have pens here we go like write
down the score on the back by the way
your hearth blue and my hair is blue
guys it's been a wild couple of days and
a hair turn blue we all got tattoos and
we've been together for 48 hours yeah 63
yeah when this goes up it'll be 63 Chris
Scott as he had done at Jenna's ratchet
so on yeah
look at that it was actually you had
your first like assistant she was
helping does she does she pay you for
your because that sounds like it
corrupts a lot you're just having we
can't always cup our employees that's
literally the only thing you need to be
able to cover I might leave a yelp
review after the lecture feeling kind of
weird about this whole thing
you're not paying your employees their
volunteer you know comment this is
negative this is she okay yeah I know
it's been fun we like never ever get to
see these guys so when they come and
visit we like to just kind of do the
most we can time we have so we mainly
online now so it's cool to see you in
the flesh
okay anyway yeah so we're they colored
hair brothers I'll leave my hat off
right now so the categories for this
game are Netflix and chill grind on me
which is a music category
once upon a time touch me there there
and nine kids 100 through 500 so I think
we should just get started let's go for
yeah all right so ladies first
we should also maybe initial so C or J
went like if we already use that
category so like to say I go first now
flicks in she'll 400 C and then you guys
will know that
hi Jordan yeah yeah yeah that's good
idea okay so hey we're course have you
get it right you get the money and if
you don't you don't yeah you got and
then and then if we get it wrong then
you move to the next scene so there's a
chance we can go the whole round but
that's impossible they're not gonna get
any right I'm gonna keep track of score
down here yep so ladies first
why don't we go with Shan alright pick a
category category don't look at yours
pick a category round here um how about
once upon a time for 300 once upon all
right so once upon I'll read the
question once upon a time for 300 and
you can guess for me for you yeah
boos age at the first time he got drunk
first time I got drama oh so close
16:14 oh yeah I think you didn't get the
points sorry so close try yeah that's
good look it really a giant goose egg
yeah do we just do that category so then
we don't have to yeah let's just do it
okay so okay why don't we just do that
all right what is my first when did I
first get nice and saucy I want to say
17 16 so that category or dude no no we
don't we don't guess you know since you
already did it since you're yeah one
question per team yeah per game
right so we'll answer each question
twice in total yeah we won't ever know
yours only wondered you can just tell us
yours tell us yours Bob let me guess
your yours is 18 no 16 okay 16 yeah I
wrote 16 or 17 November yeah I remember
my very vividly I threw up on a door
yeah yeah my friend was in the bathroom
and I couldn't get it right threw up on
the door and then there's a waterfall
bomb nice that's good that's what boys
all right so now it's our turn yeah you
missed you guys gonna ask us I'd say
pick one pick one thank you
Netflix and chill 200 booze favorite TV
show tell you to guess yours yeah
Seinfeld it's not curse of Oak Island
don't you dare not what aliens it's not
what I wrote
oh wow well um I guess I guess chance
what is it I wrote survivor and Game of
Thrones
Seinfeld is literally all you talk is
not on anymore
there is the office but here we are
alright so Shan damn it for 200 shams
favorite TV show Tim and Eric oh come on
what you probably the officers they put
the office come on yes how are you
alright I wrote Game of Thrones okay
yeah well your Thrones is your favorite
show it's a great show but we watch a
little character development for like a
month out of the year how can it be your
favorite show good so good do not defend
what is you write I wrote the office oh
now it is okay senator instead you
choose touch me there for a hundred oh
god what is the craziest place you boo
has done it aka me I'm gonna get crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay Abed prob lol let's keep moving on
that nice okay so now you guys gotta
answer it so Chris what is the craziest
place Chan's ever done it no no she has
to ask me what's the craziest place he's
ever done an EXO tree what oh that's
pretty that's actually pretty good like
a hotel bathroom that's not the tween
one's crazier you're right
wait you didn't know good next to a tree
you remember that yeah how close to the
tree like is it it was like it was like
against the church against yeah I like
that
alright Chris now you gotta pick one
wait don't you go inside you go right is
that Jeff anywhere yeah yeah
anything right yeah I'll do a grind on
me for a hundred
what is your food you booze favorite
music genre so what's his favorite music
genre don't overthink this hey don't
give it any place Alex Trebek never says
that um I'm gonna say just like popped
up for you guys got 100 we got 200 so
what do I want to guess there's what
senses just why not
favorite music shown hmm
I know yours is I don't know what it's
called it's well it's Paris rap rap yep
okay got it
what Paris considered like in like
alternative pop pop it's a lot simpler
than you're thinking um indie punk I
don't know what is it as her emo emo you
know emo emo okay I think that's yeah
that's simple I thought that was like a
few years ago no huh okay well [ __ ] it
I'm losing score well the fact that she
got you got hers right I don't think
counts cuz it was or does it count no no
we're only counting the first yeah so
we're out two hundred one hundred yeah
all right my turn again
you gotta ask me cuz we're on a roll
here oh okay you guys are like butter
oh wait take Netflix and chill 100
what's my what's your booze favorite
music movie genre movies I guess yours
yeah comedies in parentheses what movie
yes
wow you guys are good alright I'm so
proud yes nice I wrote comedy and then
also sci-fi but comedies like the first
one is funny sci-fi I think yours is
comedy also oh no no I mean no document
what is it it's a dark horror you don't
like dark movies I like dark blue no you
don't you can't even watch a horror film
she can you are in the dark : hey you
are you flexing for the podcast do you
really not like dark movies here I like
I like coolant of all your people
I wrote dark darker the question mark
dark you only watch cabin in the woods
man it's like a funny horror at the
horrifying dark okay what's a dark movie
name one darker Donnie Darko but that's
in the dark oh that oh yeah what did you
write three in a row goddamn we suck
alright let's do once upon a time for
100 you booze childhood dream job yeah I
don't think I know this a baseball
player so you got yeah alright for me
too so generous I should guess you after
that yeah yeah yes yes Jenna's ones very
specific I guess you wanted to be a
makeup artist yeah I was a little older
than you wanted to be a veterinarian
that's close I wanted to be a zookeeper
or professional soccer player was all
over the TV
remember her and oh my oh yeah OTP OTP
is bug for Shane I put mortician I was
gonna put that but I thought mortician
was the one that you wanted a these
don't wanna or the child hood but you
want to be a vet tech now yeah okay cool
okay sorry okay so you guys didn't get
that right and yet somewhere at 5-under
no Jenna so you pick another what are
you you would add it based on these oh
you only been doing hundreds okay yeah
yeah I will take nine kids for 100 point
it's like a real jeopardy players
the 100 we're not saying what the total
amount of kids that you boo once I say -
damn it destroy wow we get it dude Jesus
all right all right
what do you think mine are they - yes
nice who's a good number
get a kid have a kid have a friend each
other company and we're gonna go play
games there on five rats yeah there
should be more about pets on here five
rats okay that's not a kid okay so you
guys got the nine case you've got it all
right that's 100 okay Jenna 500 shake
grinds on me for 200 Oh
boos favorite artist see this is a
little thing you're not gonna get this
right mmm I do not know the answer I
feel like you will like one song by
someone and then suddenly there you're
like genuine that was gonna say genuine
genuine sigh my favorites you like that
song by Arcade Fire three guesses
already I had to say your favorite
artists I'm trying to determine the
gender let me think this is you're not
gonna get this right it's I know that
I'm trying to come up with an educated
guess is it no it was it rise against
okay that's there you do like residence
but Shakira was a decent second yeah
thank you thank you alright so that's a
we broke our five
was that right on me for 200 let me
guess Shan oh you guys mind yeah come on
like two bands that I can think of
tables take one New Year's yes yeah see
what what we yes for her favorite band
or artist [ __ ] okay I gotta think
Matthew a rapper it's gotta be Rihanna
right no is it a new person no isn't an
older person yeah is it a band or a
singer singing and it's not Rihanna oh
wait is it's [ __ ] up I know it is
bright side
wrong wrong but close oh [ __ ] hold on
you're right this is someone Oh what's
his name what's his name the guy this is
the guy what's his name just tell me his
name on over Conor Oberst that's pretty
nice that's what I meant to say right
side right at bright eyes I don't that's
a bright side yeah I'm stupid as hell
cuz you get on a roll for so long Jesus
Christ
quiet well it's gonna touch me there
action now let's go with Netflix and
chill for 300 I have to guess your
favorite actor no I have to guess your
favorite oh yeah Netflix in shock for
300 is whose favorite actor so what is
so it's actor a guy or a girl actor or
actress either Jake Gyllenhaal yeah yes
300 where he was a boxer who's in pre I
need all right so that's 300 and then
I'm you can get you can guess Jenna's
okay so I guess your favorite actor No
it's easy Steve Martin how would you
guess that Seth MacFarlane also no
that's no you can't have him for
multiple answers if you can't you can't
talking about one favorite actor yes
name three things that he's acted in
kids not voiceover active that's acting
wild west movie he was in Ted one into
that piece you did on 60 minutes and I
interviewed it on CNN incorrect all
right Julian's who's my favorite actor
oh it's easily Meryl Streep Sharon Yoo
Matt Damon and stuck on you or Greg
Kinnear no I went upstairs Keanu Reeves
know I love Keanu but this is Jana
Reeves eating a sandwich nope with it's
gotta be young thang data okay this if
there was a another category on this
mountain my man crash it would be that
person - oh it's quiz pad know what do
you even know me oh we said Justin
threat well done yes mine it's a guy no
idea just think just castle obviously
Chris Pratt but cuz I don't know Ryan
Gosling you never guessed that he's good
actor we're tuner Arena alright so you
there's a 300 was that that was AA 300
okay so you're killing it Jenna do we do
we hear those no we did we were all
right keep it going
let's do let's dude touch me there for
400 touch me there 400 is food that
makes boo
Randy I think that just means food that
you they like boo that makes foo Randy
boo that makes food Randy so so this is
food that maybe your favorite food yeah
wait there's so many no like the one
knows mac and cheese what weight sushi
yeah you like sushi but not like doesn't
make you Randy okay um you guess
Jenna pasta be more specific spaghetti
meatballs Oh was it
I shan't guess my no it's no I don't
almost yeah it's like 50/50 split these
nachos and burger and wings - okay well
yeah I have so many of our foods and so
do you is it your turn it's my turn okay
everyone likes food it's very hard stop
licking my tattoo peach yeah I'll take
Squarespace for six hundred speaking of
Squarespace right now you guys can start
your own blog or website using
Squarespace
they have a bunch of different templates
for you to try that's a good thing what
I didn't do anything because if you've
been thinking about starting a website
and you're scared of all the of what
goes into it the coding everything it's
made easy with Squarespace okay they
have 24/7 customer support they have
many many many different templates and
styles for you to choose from if you'd
like an online store an online shop or
even just a blog or you need a website
for your business your small business
Squarespace is the way to do it I'm
telling you guys having an all-in-one
platform where you can adjust things on
your website with the help of 24/7
customer support is amazing and I've
used it and it's super helpful and you
can make websites that are way cooler
than you ever thought you can make so
check it out okay see what it's all
about see the hype is all about make a
beautiful website wow us with it and
tweet it at us so we can look at it by
going to Squarespace comm slots Jenna
and Julian or click the link in the
description you get 10% off is it an and
or an ampersand it's an and thank you
you're welcome
or you just click the link it's easier
that way Squarespace comps on Angela and
you 10% of your first purchase of a
website or domain so if you're looking
to test it out right now or even start a
blog or even something that you don't
even know what you want to do you just
want to mess around go the website check
it out a square space they will help you
along the way
award-winning 24/7 customer support
that's not a joke 24/7 24 hours a day
they'll help you with your [ __ ] it's
amazing
check it out right now think it dream it
make it with Squarespace thank you okay
I will choose Netflix and chill for 400
what is it whose favorite movie the jerk
yeah I wrote airplane or the jerk nice
good job
got it oh it's um we is it it's the it's
the guy labyrinth is the other one yeah
wait what's one with the boo in the babe
is that the one yeah what does it call
yeah but that's not it
labyrinth is good I didn't write that oh
what'd you write the Dark Crystal
doctor's your favorite movie only sucks
really glad with more I do but I didn't
write it
sorry that what labyrinth is that my
better what did you make
there's no you're guessing I never um
the one with the driving with the Ryan
Gosling drive
that's top five so I don't know Seven
Samurai
Oh cure curse out I would have guessed
that classic cinematic misreading what
it's really mate um stuck on yeah see
you got to 302 100 what was that one
that was 400 you get that one right guys
no no okay so we did so suck it Wow all
right I will choose grant no once upon a
time for 200 house good guess I mean
that read what it is no one someone else
reads it who's first age they got into
legal trouble okay so I can tell this
entire story but I I was confused if it
was at 16 or 18 so I think I'm gonna go
with I'm gonna go with 18 what's the
story when you were drove without the
license in the arrested you I was not 18
hours in college college I got a
speeding ticket one time when I was like
19 but I would accept yeah I got
arrested wait a speeding ticket that
wasn't it trouble I wasn't 18 I thought
you were younger when I was like 22
right thanks alright what was my first
legal trouble I think you've ever been
in the law and I have gotten along very
well in my life yeah I've never been in
legal trouble that's what I said angel
Shan 19 lock me up I think it was 19 I
wrote it not that age but I think I mean
you might Bob's
yes yep what's Bob's what did you steal
to nobody
her lesson where they dug she is that
they were for my boyfriend at the time
what I can steal shoes for you never
19th a second I wrote 18 but it's
definitely 19 yeah that one was a tough
one do we get points if I got it right
there no no what did you what did you do
that's mine no guys don't even know you
done just think oh I know yeah yes on
himself
yeah how old oh my god 17 no you know
were you high school
why are you guessing I'm gonna say 16
1900 yeah I was in Community College
oh yes hello is me Chris mailbag I'd
like to report me highest I own one
might smoke two cigarettes and I think
I'm dying
[Music]
no it's cool
all right now it's Shannon take the
board I'm going to ask you
no no no don't read that page I'm
reading myself so I know okay okay um
how about nine kids for 300 nine kids
for 300
the question is booze dream job what's
my dream job baseball player no no no oh
that was my childhood dream job what's
my dream job currently um video game
player I don't know babe I honestly have
no idea acting in a comedy film hmm
that'd be cool eventually to do that
branch out thanks I want to be playing
videos we'd love to I'm just saying like
that'd be cool to be like I'm in a movie
being a movie I'll direct it thank you
wait what do you think I put
well let Jenna guess Jillian's first hmm
[Music]
I don't know
I'd say what your current job is or just
a stay-at-home dad
stay-at-home dad directing an original
Netflix series
that's cheating I'm not gonna accept it
it was helping you know and you still
got it wrong okay
Shan who your dream job I think would
just be like like just being a
full-blown photographer and shooting
anything unless oh you picked a real
answer what's yours just [ __ ] killing
it the same thing your dream job
basically have a farm full of animals
and foster Oliver yeah I will my I guess
my current job and or on the farm that's
great I'm done all up in a far more like
old or no you [ __ ] up wait don't we
have to exile you let up got a pan
what did I do it was this this one right
these dogs are so well behaved by the
way good job
let's do nine kids for 200 booze dream
car um oh your dream car I just made one
up let me say like uh I don't know oh
just like a fancier version of what you
have like a Honda with no roof
whoa guys you're the Honda that's crazy
eyes are a big-ass truck that's cause I
would love to have a big ass truck at
some point my life I don't have a dream
car
really yes my chin a BMW yes so we only
get the points if you guys don't get the
points yeah okay that's but now I'm
gonna guess Jenna's for fun yeah is it
just your current car yeah I said um any
seven passengers you'd be nothing to
fans I think I know what is it a beetle
yes like a souped-up beetles all right
so my turn
yep nice babe yeah that was a 99 - okay
wait do we also answer no let's go with
once upon a time for 500 oh [ __ ] we're
going it's the age yeah boo lost our
innocence that means sex right I think
that means sex like me lost your
virginity at that age
we're still waiting I'm sure um I'm
gonna go with 19 yes really
yeah late bloomer yeah late bloomer all
right you can put you can Marcus after
five hundred please all right good job
oh yeah I guess you know m16 I wrote 17
or something.idk I don't run pretty much
the same I think it's 17 for me I don't
run yeah I it's there's no definite
answer I think it's 17 though kiss me
weren't you 18 19
yes dude all right keep it going don't
roll okay I grind on me for 500 [ __ ] it
oh my god your couples song
what is your couples okay I hope I get
this right
he is we happily ever after
I wrote use me yes wouldn't you know
what you know yeah I like to know uh Oh
seen a similar image oh it's good little
hop and nothing Buchi hey laufen eh
Oh screw the bowfin cabin oh she can pay
for dolphin you're good give me one more
song and sing it so much I'll do it
right now
firework Katy Perry
cheap and open coffin please both oh I
think I think Chris was a sim in his
last life Babi Yar for where did you get
that yeah just come with me loca you do
it so which ones that do that feel like
a plastic bag oh yeah do you ever fall
Luka plastic bag drifting through the
wound morning tooth dirt that's hard see
this add another 5 hundo what is that
you're you're a couple soft
I picked lay me down by Sam Smith that's
what I've wrote else though nidito
but we have a different song to guess
for the song that we would play for you
right it's a different one right song
you would dedicate to your boo best
everyone okay is it annoying that I'm
doing all the 500s there's a fun no it's
a very Chris thing
touch me there for 500 touch me there
for 500 let's check him out of the way
celebrity sex list
you know for you boo Jake Gyllenhaal is
in great shape you should check it I
don't know I don't want to watch just
get a poster of it so what is so I have
to guess your celebrity sex list number
one second Farland yeah okay correction
guess mine you know it like the guy in
Drive know your girl excuse me why is a
guy the first guest celebrity oh dami a
lot yes we talk about literally the
other night bowling last night nice all
right you're okay
I'll save some 5-hundred for you guys
let's see what nine kids for four
hundred the name you boo wouldn't choose
for your next child so there's no
[ __ ] way I'm getting this strangle
that word - you mean something then I
would never want to name a kid
[Laughter]
realistically though I have no idea
I wrote spray spray spray get in here
angled better use your support I didn't
you spray a girl named Dylan that's cute
that was the name of my ferret damn it
why was it's a girl name with a guy's
name okay can I give you a hint though
because it's it's not a girl child yeah
it's a girl me oh I don't know I wrote
down a guy's name for a child yeah fur
dude okay baby
Chris is a good name is it is it Seth Oh
that'd be weird I don't know would you
like to know yeah it's Jerry Seinfeld's
Alvida he can be in all my videos it's a
me and we're not clicking finding also
San Fran Sol Amita whatever there that's
mine I actually picked the normal one
for a guy or a girl girl hmm I don't
know me neither I made it up at the time
then I don't guess one it's pretty bad
reference Kyle saw [ __ ] girl [ __ ]
crystal meth it's a great honour roof'd
the character and Breaking Bad these
beaver Badgers badger know it's a good
note Jane what it's just a name okay
name I'm freaking out Jane solo Mina you
wrote ever I will not be booed off my
own podcast here no booing no no no yeah
thank you
no booing that's rule number four yeah
Jane what are we 1993 is it your turn
now I'm gonna take this thing home
Netflix and chill 500 first movie you
guys saw the other devil movie on my
dad's account so we rented a movie
called devil that's about it no it's an
elevator oh yeah
looks terrible with that so bad but we
never returned it every house they move
into I'm like unpacking unpacking and
I'm like where did this come from you
you moved it to every house you've ever
lived in hey when is it say yes exactly
what it's an important memory you just
blame it I'm honestly gonna frame it
you shouldn't have devil the movies
blockbuster case all right we got five
oh yeah cross off Netflix and chill for
500 you had the three 500 products I had
a - we have three all right so now I'm
gonna go
I put inception exactly my favorite
movie in college I know honestly it now
then think about I think it's Drive
might have been Drive in your basement
oh you guys are cute that's good time oh
thanks Brooke Netflix and chill two
hundred nobody do that one okay yeah
it's all done grind on me 400 okay I
need to know that question no 1 song
your boo would dedicate to you you
dedicate to me I wrote what okay I have
the answer for what I don't get you
um [ __ ] that's not good song that you
would dedicate to me the office theme
song absolutely not
mine word the same as the art whatever
our song is Jamie down yeah or else Odin
detail yeah okay fair enough
is that the same for you is that 400 put
down our school friends uh-huh yeah I
don't repeat any answers is confusing to
me sorry I didn't gosh and Europe
Shane Europe yes
because um let's do once upon time for
200 because it's not cross down no we
did that one ready
Oh cross it huh
booze 200 so once upon time to perform
into it is that done
whose favorite relationship memory okay
you guess what's yeah
Vegas hmm
Germany oh that was a good one I've
known that actually just from seeing so
much my outside damn know we have so
many memories visiting which one did
what was that again tell us 400 once
upon a time so thank you I'll give you
general give you a hint no no no cuz she
could snag me points oh yeah I think hmm
I don't know don't know oh I know I know
I never one-hit wake I guess fine I know
what it is yeah where that was Palm
Springs yeah I didn't write that
that was good night Palm Springs hot tub
night I'll tell you what I wrote was
that day on the beach with one of mine
oh oh the one no that was real I was
like one of my favorite night maintains
best day ever
I wrote Santa Barbara when you forgot
your wall and I forgot my jacket
Oh
that was like such a fun little trip
damn like literally didn't have a wallet
and I didn't have my it was freezing in
Julia's like I'm so cold I'm like don't
worry let's just jump in so I'll get you
a sweatshirt or something that's like
what do you put every time we travel we
travel a lot yeah you guys are cute
Germany was that was 5-hour 400 of once
bonus okay all right I think there's
only like touch me there yeah touch me
there for two hundo whose fantasy sex
spot my god
is this like a body place or a physical
location was my fantasy sexpot don't
mine you think I saw so you're guessing
my oh my oh no lol no damn it
oh oh I was waiting for you to guess
mine no I wrote back of the US the US I
guess yours now
yeah on a farm you guess mine I mean you
can get points here in a park in a
fortnight's hour you work together on
that we did um in a bed you want to do
it no trouble guy Alan I got a beach
hello yes travel agent let's go see your
Barbados right now
two tickets Thanks
guys the podcast was great but we gotta
go no time there's one left there's
there's one to miss Portland oh there's
one though those are all just forgot to
be marked there's only one left
actually wait there's a few left yeah
touch me there
I think touched me there for 300 and
then kids that want tell me the nine
kids for five hundred all right let me
so let's do a touch me there for three
hundred Shan what do you mean that's the
one that I'm guessing for you there were
three hundred is booze stream strangest
turn on what's her strange is turn on Oh
God did you did you pick a funny thing
or serious thing I mean [ __ ] now
let's see you know it do I actually know
it yeah really
you have to know it no Vince I know you
know it Chris be my answer you could say
in front of people so I don't know I
don't know dude look massaging you
I wrote ASMR carrots
hey it's of our carrots turns you I love
the sound it's crunchy that turns you on
what do you what I put call you daddy
no ears getting nibble yeah I was
kidding
ears getting dead nibbles Jenna what's
what's my there's more carrots you have
to guess mine oh that's right um your
turn on when you revive um
mac and cheese in bed I'm sorry I mean
you know yeah
do you want to know whatever all i'm
gonna keep guessing okay I already lost
the punch but I want to guess mm-hmm I'm
[ __ ] to say Kermit don't whine
me dressing up in a full suit oh my god
let me just read you one up okay when
Julian hits those vine references
perfect I was country boy in stereo
that's what that was mine when I get a
headshot in pub G pretty much but I'm
not cooking food naked I don't know yeah
oh you're the last you get the last
question what is it five hundred nine
kids nine kids
yeah who's first lottery purchase that's
his name make sense I know I had a lot
of scratcher at a gas station with you a
couple years ago as my first one how was
your first one - I was 18 I put what
anti-climatic wait I think it's like
what's your first thing you're gonna buy
out you in the lottery
I already have it for Sam you know what
my Debbie yeah can I write it down you
write it down then I write mine down no
faster so guess guess I think it's -
wait so who's got em guys
all right what are you writing Chris I'm
pretty I'm running might actually cuz I
brought yours for my answer oh you kept
doing that Julie yes mine just to buy a
[ __ ] full-on farm my first lottery
purchase would not be a farm it was to
buy a house in Big Bear a car just a
greyhound Oh blah
we're gonna get one with that we're
likely gonna end up with one without a
lottery ticket purchase though but it
would still be my first purchase okay my
purchase - and I guess what mine would
be oh it's thick and PC fair enough no I
would I would I would pay to have the
office renewed and pay everyone their
payrolls and everything yeah that's very
nice
that's Exhibit A in our divorce I put
for you your you would get you'd want to
get like a house or cottage in the woods
what the [ __ ] are all the animals - um a
house or cottage in the woods no pay off
my family's loans that's realistic you
know I mean you're a good guy okay
podcast
twice right I think Chris one they got
so many five hundreds yeah they want it
was five fifteen hundred plus six
hundred plus 200 no I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
twenty-five hundred - a 200 for just
[ __ ] killing it so you definitely
beat us we ended up with like maybe it
was really cool I think we all got to
know ya boo
that was a Parks and Rec game just so
you know you just participated in our
long Parks and Rec reference you did
what sparks right I take it all back
good stuff no you boo thank you guys for
hanging out while we show you how well
we know our blue make sure to check out
Chris he streams all the time on Twitch
and he's incredibly entertaining them on
it's Oscars bumper down and Shan we will
link both of them below so make sure you
send our guests some love thank you
thank you guys for helping us make the
freshest of content hopefully we can
have you on another time but for now is
gonna he's gonna be time to go play some
more video games and stuff but hope you
you guys have a great week thanks for
hanging out and I will see you in the
next one
thank you so much guys
[Music]
[Music]